[Musique]
c'est chaud c'est mon honneur pour tous
les égards et l'afrique même acabit
gratton quand tout la pluie pleurent
nous demande est rejetée
devant la télévision
hier après-midi dans le
mouvement
ministre patrick achi a annoncé la
nouvelle il faut dire que sur place il a
été très choqué vraiment mal parce que
c'est terminé
le premier ministre est un grand homme
politique est là toujours peser ses mots
on a toujours fait la politique sans
violence et c'est ce que j'ai vraiment
apprécié lui ce sont ce genre de
personnage politique
dans ce pays beaucoup plus d'un mois
n'est jamais heureux on peut être
quelqu'un d'autre halgand pousseur d'un
travailleur mais bon ainsi va la vie
quoi
comme ça
oui
[Musique]